[Music]
[Applause]
so
i'll start with this a couple of years
ago an event planner called me because i
was going to do a speaking event
and she called and she said i'm really
struggling with how to write about you
on the little flyer
and i thought well what's the struggle
and she said well i saw you speak and i
i i'm going to call you a researcher i
think but i'm afraid if i call your
researcher no one will come because
they'll think you're boring and
irrelevant
and it's like okay and she said so but
the thing i liked about your talk is you
know you're a storyteller so i think
what i'll do is just call you a
storyteller
and of course the academic insecure part
of me was like
you're gonna call me a what and she said
i'm gonna call you a storyteller and i
was like
oh why not magic pixie
i was like i i don't i let me think
about this for a second and so
i tried to call deep on my courage and i
thought
you know i am a storyteller i'm a
qualitative researcher i collect stories
that's what i do
and maybe stories are just data with a
soul you know and maybe i'm just
a storyteller so i said you know what
why don't you just say i'm a researcher
storyteller
and she went there's no such thing
so i'm a researcher or storyteller and
i'm going to talk to you today we're
talking about expanding
perception and so i want to talk to you
and tell some stories about
a piece of my research that
fundamentally expanded my perception
and really actually changed the way that
i live and love and work and parent
and this is where my story starts when i
was a young researcher doctoral student
my first year i had a research professor
who said to us
here's the thing if you cannot measure
it it does not
exist and i thought he was just sweet
talking me i was like
really and he's like absolutely so you
have to understand that i have
a bachelor's in social work a master's
in social work and i was getting my phd
in social work so my entire academic
career
was surrounded by people who kind of
believed in the life's messy
love it you know and i'm more the life's
messy
clean it up organize it and put it into
a bento box
um and so to
think that i had found my way to found a
career
that takes me you know really one of the
big sayings
in in social work is lean into the
discomfort of the work
and i'm like you know knock discomfort
upside the head and move it over
and get all a's that's my that was my
mantra
so i was very excited about this and so
i thought you know what
this is the career for me because i am
interested in some messy topics
but i want to be able to make them not
messy
i want to understand them i want to hack
into these things i know are important
and lay the code out for everyone to see
so where i started
was with connection because by the time
you're a social worker for
10 years what you realize is that
connection is why we're here it's what
gives purpose and meaning to our lives
this is this is what it's all about it
doesn't matter whether you talk to
people who work in social justice and
mental health
and abuse and neglect what we know is
that connection
the ability to feel connected is
neurobiologically that's how we're wired
it's why we're here
so i thought you know what i'm going to
start with connection
well you know that that situation where
you get an evaluation from your boss
and she tells you 37 things that you do
really awesome and one thing that you
can't you know an opportunity for growth
and all you can think about is that
opportunity for growth right
well apparently this is the way my work
went as well because
when you ask people about love they tell
you about heartbreak
when you ask people about belonging
they'll tell you the most
excruciating experiences of being
excluded
and when you ask people about connection
the stories they told me were about
disconnection
so very quickly really about six weeks
into this research i ran into
this unnamed thing that absolutely
unraveled connection
in a way that i didn't understand or had
never seen and so i pulled back out of
the research and thought i need to
figure out what this is
and it turned out to be shame
and shame is really easily understood as
the fear of disconnection
is there something about me that if
other people know it or see it
that i won't be worthy of connection
the things i can tell you about it's
universal we all have it the only people
who don't experience shame have no
capacity for human
empathy or connection no one wants to
talk about it and the less you talk
about it the more you have it
what underpinned this shame this i'm not
good enough
which we all know that feeling i'm not
blank enough i'm not thin enough rich
enough beautiful enough smart enough
promoted enough um the thing that
underpinned this
was excruciating vulnerability
this idea of in order for connection to
happen
we have to allow ourselves to be seen
really seen
and you know how i feel about
vulnerability i hate vulnerability and
so
i thought this is my chance to beat it
back with my measuring stick
i'm going in i'm going to figure this
stuff out i'm going to spend a year
i'm going to totally deconstruct shame
i'm going to understand how
vulnerability works and i'm going to
outsmart it
so i was ready and i was really excited
as you know it's not going to turn out
well
you know this so i could tell you a lot
about shame
but i'd have to borrow everyone else's
time but here's what i can tell you that
it boils down to
and this may be one of the most
important things that i've ever learned
in the decade of doing this research
my one years turned into six years
thousands of stories hundreds of long
interviews
focus groups at one point people were
sending me journal pages and sending me
their stories
thousands of pieces of data and six
years
and i kind of got a handle on it i kind
of understood this is what shame is this
is how it works
i wrote a book i published a theory
but something was not okay and what it
was is that if i roughly took the people
i interviewed
and divided them into people
who really have a sense of worthiness
that's what this comes down to a sense
of worthiness
they have a strong sense of love and
belonging
and folks who struggle for it and folks
who are always
wondering if they're good enough there
was only one variable that separated the
people who have a strong sense of love
and belonging
and the people who really struggle for
it and that was the people who have a
strong sense of love and belonging
believe they're worthy of love and
belonging
that's it they believe they're worthy
and to me the hard part of
the one thing that keeps us out of
connection is our fear that we're not
worthy of connection
with something that personally and
professionally i felt like i needed to
understand better
so what i did is i
took all of the interviews where i saw
worthiness where i saw people living
that way
and just looked at those what do these
people have in common and i have
i have a slight office supply addiction
but that's another talk
so i had a manila notebook a manila
folder and i had a sharpie
and i was like what am i going to call
this research and the first words that
came to my mind were
wholehearted these are kind of
wholehearted people living from this
deep sense of worthiness so i wrote at
the top of the manila folder
and i started looking at the data in
fact i did it first
in this very four in a four day
very intensive data analysis where i
went back pulled these interviews pulled
the stories pulled the incidents
what's the what's the theme what's the
pattern
my husband left town with the kids um
because i always go into this kind of
jackson pollock crazy thing where i'm
just like
writing and going and kind of just in my
researcher mode
and so here's what i found
what they had in common was a sense of
courage
and i want to separate courage and
bravery for you for a minute
courage the original definition of
courage when it first came into the
english language it's from the latin
word cur
meaning heart and the original
definition was to tell the story of who
you are with your whole heart
and so these folks had very simply the
courage to be imperfect
they had the compassion to be kind to
themselves first
and then to others because as it turns
out we can't practice compassion with
other people if we can't treat ourselves
kindly
and the last was they had connection and
this was the hard part
as a result of authenticity they were
willing to let go of who they thought
they should be
in order to be who they were which is
you have to
absolutely do that for connection
the other thing that they had in common
was this
they fully embraced vulnerability
they believed
that what made them vulnerable made them
beautiful
they didn't talk about vulnerability
being comfortable
nor did they really talk about it being
excruciating as i had heard
earlier in the shame interviewing they
just talked about it being necessary
they talked about the willingness to say
i love you first
the willingness to
do something where there are no
guarantees
the willingness to breathe through
waiting for the doctor to call after
your mammogram
the willing to invest in a relationship
that may or may not work out they
thought this was fundamental
i personally thought it was betrayal
i could not believe i had pledged
allegiance to research
where our job you know the definition of
research is to control control and
predict
a steady phenomenon for the reason for
this explicit reason to control and
predict
and now my very you know my mission to
control and predict
had turned up the answer that the way to
live is with vulnerability
and to stop controlling and predicting
this led to
a little breakdown
which actually looked more like this
and it did it led to a i called a
breakdown my therapist calls it a
spiritual awakening
spiritual lightning sounds better than
breakdown but i assure you it was a
breakdown
and i had to put my data away and go
find a therapist let me tell you
something
you know who you are when you call your
friends and say i think i need to see
somebody
who do you have any recommendations
because about five my friend's like
i wouldn't want to be your therapist um
and i was like what does that mean and
they're like i'm just saying you know
like
don't bring your measuring stick
okay so i found a therapist
my first meeting with her diana
i brought in my list of the way the
wholehearted live
and i sat down and she said you know how
are you and i said
i'm great you know i'm i'm okay and she
said what's going on and i said
and this is a therapist who sees
therapists because
we have to go to those because their bs
meters are
good
and so i said here's the thing i'm
struggling
and she said what's the struggle and i
said well i have a vulnerability issue
and you know and i know that
vulnerability is kind of the core
of shame and fear and our struggle for
worthiness
but it appears that it's also the
birthplace of joy
of creativity a belonging of love
and i think i have a problem and
i just i need some help and i said but
here's the thing
no family stuff no childhood [__] i just
i just need some strategies
thank you um
so she goes like this
and then i said it's bad right she said
it's neither good nor bad
it just is what it is and i said oh my
god this is gonna
suck um
and it did and it didn't um and it took
about a year
and you know how there are people that
like when they realize that
vulnerability
and tenderness are important that they
kind of surrender and walk into it
a that's not me and b i don't even hang
out with people like that
for me it was a year-long street fight
it was a slugfest vulnerability pushed i
pushed back
i lost the fight but
probably won my life back and so then i
went back into the research and spent
the next couple of years
really trying to understand what they
the wholehearted
um what the choices they were making and
and what what is
what what are we doing with
vulnerability why
do we struggle with it so much am i
alone in struggling with vulnerability
no so this is what i learned
we numb vulnerability when we're waiting
for the call
it was funny i sent something out on
twitter and on facebook that says
how would you define vulnerability what
makes you feel vulnerable and within an
hour and a half i had 150 responses
because i wanted to know you know what's
out there
having to ask my husband for help
because i'm sick and we're newly married
um initiating sex with my husband
initiating sex with my wife being turned
down
asking someone out waiting for the
doctor to call back
getting laid off laying off people this
is the world we live in
we live in a vulnerable world and one of
the ways we deal with it is we numb
vulnerability
and i think there's evidence and it's
not the only reason this evidence exists
but i think that there it's a huge cause
we are the most in debt
obese addicted
and medicated adult cohort in u.s
history
the problem is and i learned this from
the research
that you cannot selectively numb emotion
you can't say here's the bad stuff
here's vulnerability here's grief here's
shame here's fear here's disappointment
i don't want to feel these i'm going to
have a couple of beers and a banana nut
muffin
i don't want to feel these and i know
that's i know that's knowing laughter i
i hack into your lives for a living i
know that's oh god
you can't numb those hard feelings
without numbing the other affects our
emotions you cannot selectively numb
so when we numb those we numb
joy we numb gratitude
we numb happiness and then
we are miserable and we are looking for
purpose and meaning
and then we feel vulnerable so then we
have a couple of beers and a banana nut
muffin
and it becomes this dangerous cycle um
one of the things that i think that we
need to think about
is why and how we numb and it doesn't
just have to be addiction
the other thing we do is we make
everything that's uncertain certain
religion has gone from a belief in faith
and mystery
to certainty i'm right you're wrong shut
up
that's it just certain
the more afraid we are the more
vulnerable we are the more
afraid we are this is what politics
looks like today there's no discourse
anymore
there's no conversation there's just
blame you know what blame you know how
blame is described in the research
a way to discharge pain and discomfort
we perfect if there's anyone who wants
their life to look like this
it would be me but it doesn't work
because what we do is we take fat from
our butts and put it in our cheeks
which just i hope in 100 years people
will look back and go wow
and we perfect most dangerously are
children
let me tell you what we think about
children they're hardwired for struggle
when they get here
when you hold those perfect little
babies in your hand our job is not to
say
look at her she's perfect my job is just
to keep her perfect make sure she makes
the tennis team by fifth grade and yale
by seventh grade
that's not our job our job is to look
and say you know what you're imperfect
and you're
wired for struggle but you are worthy of
love and belonging
that's our job show me a generation of
kids raised like that
and we'll end the problems i think that
we see today
we pretend
that what we do doesn't have an effect
on people
we do that in our personal lives we do
that corporate whether it's a bailout an
oil spill
a recall we pretend like what we're
doing doesn't have a huge impact on
other people
i would say to companies this is not our
first rodeo people
we just need you to be authentic and
real and say
we're sorry we'll fix it
but there's another way and i'll leave
you with this this is what i have found
to let ourselves be seen deeply seen
vulnerably seen
to love with our whole hearts even
though there's no guarantee
and that's really hard and i can tell
you as a parent that's excruciatingly
difficult
to practice gratitude and joy in those
moments of kind of terror
when we're wondering can i love you this
much can i believe in this as
passionately
can i be this fierce about this just to
be able to stop and instead of
catastrophizing what might happen to say
i'm just so grateful
because to feel this vulnerable means
i'm alive
and the last which i think is probably
the most important
is to believe that we're enough because
when we work from a place
i believe that says i'm enough
then we stop screaming and start
listening
we're kinder and gentler to the people
around us and we're kinder and gentler
to ourselves
that's all i have
[Music]
sharing that's video on the human
network
cisco welcome to the human network